hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the four levels of protein
structure and when we talk about
structure we're usually talking about
the 3d arrangement of atoms and space
and the reason that we care about
protein structure is because structure
impacts function this means that if a
protein does not have the correct
structure perhaps because of the
mutation then it's unlikely to be able
to function correctly now there are four
levels of protein structure primary
secondary tertiary and quaternary and
those are what we're going to focus on
in this video
primary structure is often abbreviated
as a1 with a little degree sign so
that's a way that you can read it in
your notes primary structure refers to
the sequence of amino acid monomers
along the polypeptide chain and these
amino acids are held together by peptide
bonds that are formed by a kind of
reaction called a dehydration reaction
or a dehydration synthesis reaction so
basically this is when you have two
amino acids like I've drawn one in blue
and one in orange here and it's called
dehydration because they lose a water
molecule this H and this Oh H come
together to form h2o and those are lost
from the molecule and the result is you
get a peptide bond that's formed between
this carbon and this nitrogen and that
peptide bond is gone here in black so
this is what the primary the primary
structure of a protein is it's simply
the amino acids in the polypeptide chain
maybe there's forty or fifty amino acids
maybe there's 100 or 150 maybe there's
over 200 but whatever that number
it's just the amino acids as they are
lined up down the length of the
polypeptide helps together by those
peptide bonds secondary structures where
we get to be a little bit more
complicated we can abbreviate secondary
structure as a two with a degree symbol
so secondary structure refers to local
sub structures that are formed by
hydrogen bonds between main chain atoms
and you might have heard of the name of
some of the secondary structures alpha
helix YZ and theta beta sheets or beta
pleated sheets and so these are the two
main kinds of secondary structure and
the important way to distinguish them
from other types of protein structure
has to do with the fact that they're
these local sub structures specifically
formed by hydrogen bonds between main
chain atoms let me show you what I mean
by that here I have drawn a portion of
an alpha helix so we can see you've got
the the main chain is referring to this
nitrogen carbon carbon nitrogen carbon
carbon backbone and also to the
hydrogen's that are on those nitrogen
groups we are not talking about our
groups our groups being the different
groups that give different amino acids
their different properties we're just
talking about the nitrogen and
hydrogen's and also these carbons and
the oxygens that are on them and so I've
drawn this here the carbons are in black
and I fins are in blue the hydrogens are
in orange and the oxygens are in red and
I have drawn various hydrogen bonds
between these components and green
dashed lines I'm going to go over them
now in purple just to make sure you can
see them but so we've got a hydrogen
bond between the oxygen on this carbon
and the hydrogen on this nitrogen
another hydrogen bond here another one
here another one here this hydrogen can
form a hydrogen bond with a main chain
atom that's above it this one can form a
hydrogen bond with a main chain atoms
below it so it's these hydrogen bonds
between the different components in the
amino acids that allow this helical
structure or a beta sheet structure to
form and that's what we mean by
secondary structure now it's going to
talking about tertiary structure which
we can abbreviate like this so it refers
to the 3d lobular structure formed by
interactions between those R groups
remember we said that R groups which
I'll circle right here are these
components that are attached to the
Alpha carbon in each amino acid and
these R groups have various properties
they can be hydrophilic they can be
hydrophobic they can have a sulfur group
that's capable of covalently bonding to
a sulphur birth and another R group they
can be charged they can be uncharged and
so they have a lot of different
potential properties and where the
secondary structure was hydrogen bonds
between main chain atoms that are not
part of those R groups tertiary
structure is referring to different
kinds of interactions between those
arthurs Stolte bridges this is another
word for ionic interactions so salt
bridges are when you have two different
charged R groups
so once positive and ones negative and
they can be in completely different
parts of that polypeptide structure and
yet they come together in space to
associate with each other and form an
ionic interaction hydrogen bonds are are
similar where you have various
hydrophilic our groups polar R groups
capable of hydrogen bond
and they can interact through those
hydrogen bonds disulfide bonds are when
you have to our groups again they can be
in completely different parts of the
polypeptide chain both of them have
these sulfurs that come together and can
covalently bond to form what we call
disulfide bond or disulfide bridges and
then also hydrophobic interactions if
you have R groups that are non polar
they don't like to associate with water
or other hydrophilic things so the
polypeptide will fold and space into
this 3d configuration that puts all of
those hydrophobic amino acids into sort
of the middle of the polypeptide and
they can interact with each other there
and be kind of protected from water and
the other hydrophilic R groups and so in
the end you get a 3d structure that
looks something like this you can see
that it has many alpha helixes as many
beta pleated sheets but those are those
units of secondary structure just kind
of fold up based on our group
interactions to create this this
functional sort of 3d structure so now
what's going to talk about the ternary
structure which we will abbreviate like
this keep in mind that quaternary
structure does not apply to every
protein and that's because quaternary
structure refers to the aggregation of
two or more polypeptides
so when you have two or more
polypeptides
that aggregates together through a
variety of potential interactions into a
single functional unit then a protein
has quaternary structure however there
are many many proteins that that only
have up to tertiary structure that means
they've got primary they've got
secondary and they've got tertiary
structure they're comprised of one
polypeptide chain that's folded into a
functional 3d unit and that's it they
don't have more than one polypeptide
until they don't have the ternary
structure however many important
proteins do have quaternary structure on
top of the primary secondary and
tertiary structures that they all have
and this is because many proteins are
comprised of more than one polypeptide
and let's talk about three examples of
that the first one is one that you've
probably heard of insulin so insulin
comes into the conversation when we talk
about the human disease deities but
insulin is a heterodimer and what that
means dimer means that it's composed of
two polypeptides hetero means that those
two polypeptides are different so you
have an a chain and B chain and the a
chain and the B chain are stabilized
together by disulfide bonds or disulfide
bridges so they've got those are groups
that have sulfur's in them and and two
of those sulfur is covalently bond and
that's how we get the disulfide name and
that's what stabilizes insulin and so
the a chain by itself is not functional
the be chaining by itself is not
functional but the two come together to
form a single functional unit called
insulin our next example is a protein
that you have also probably heard of
called collagen
so collagen is important for the tensile
strength and flexibility of our skin for
example so collagen is a homo dimer
trimer because it's 3 polypeptides a
homo because those 3 polypeptides are
the same so three identical polypeptide
chains that are stabilized by a large
number of hydrogen bond and that is what
forms they actually form kind of a
triple helix type structure and that's
what collagen looks like and then our
final example is another commonly
recognized protein called hemoglobin
hemoglobin is important it is at high
concentrations in our red blood cells
and hemoglobin is what carries oxygen
from our lungs to our tissues and so
quite important for cellular function
obviously and hemoglobin is a hetero
tetra mer tetra mer because it's
actually four polypeptide chains hetero
because they're not all the same it's
actually two alpha chains that are
identical and two beta chains that are
identical and those two alpha chains and
two beta and form this hetero tetramer
known as Emma globin and it is a very
large protein capable of bonding up to
four oxygens and transporting the two
tissues in the body and it is stabilized
by a variety of interactions including
salt bridges hydrogen bonds and
hydrophobic interactions and so keep in
mind that these same kinds of
interactions that stabilize tertiary
structure are useful in a ternary
structure as well it's just an inertia
airy structure these are happening
between our moods in the same
polypeptide and in quaternary structure
they're happening between our groups and
different polypeptides if you are
interested in learning some more about
some of these
thanks I've got a couple of other videos
you might be interested in one is a
video on dehydration synthesis reactions
and hydrolysis reactions that are useful
in building up polymers like
polypeptides and other macromolecules
another one that you might be interested
in is my video on introduction to
enzymes where you can learn about the
the function and the structure of
various enzymes that are important in
human physiology so check those out and
thanks for watching biology professor
today